my project for my body was pretty much
one arm has the quote-unquote bad stuff
on it and on this arm else all the good
stuff a positive stuff on it so on the
side of skulls and hearts and daggers
and and like a deity an evil deity and
snakes and on the side I've I know
hearts and flowers and birds branding is
kind of like turning over a new leaf
it's like turning over a new chapter
I am excited um just get wait to see the
final product I'm not excited with the
pain part of it so I haven't tried and
try not to think about that I'm more
nervous about the smell of the burning
skin I guess there are a lot of likes
negative stereotypes about branding and
in general I guess for me I don't really
see them that much like I really just
see the art like the beauty than which
you could create
y'all excited yeah gonna kill me McGirt
feel hurt and it'll hurt good good this
art of scarification whether it's
branding or cutting essentially is a is
the art of guesstimation the placement
of the body of the skill of the artist
genetics and how a person scars the last
one is how they choose to take care of
it all these things help to determine
how thick and how raised the scar is
gonna be okay there Doyle is so
basically the bikes gonna be facing
outward yes and then try to stand so
you're really even right till your body
is just normal fine a nice good center
spot we should just fast forward so I
just get the whole ordeal with classes
more into the finished product rather
than the actual experience right now
lookee there Joyce okay ready he'll do
one then two don't worry
I don't see it as harming a skin my skin
I'm adding like more decoration to it
from the makeup almost is where could
you hear it oh it does hurt it's just
adding your personal touch to it it's
not really damaging it some parts I'm
trying not to wince
I guess what choice we're done yeah
how's that good good and I think the
message is I own my body I want to do
something creative with it and I I don't
mind that you find it offensive you know
anyone can get a tattoo everybody's
getting tattoos now everybody's getting
pierced but you don't see too many
brandings most people nothing they want
to feel the pain but I have to say they
don't want to hide anything either they
want the real full experience when I go
through some pain um I don't know why I
like it
I like it it's it makes you feel alive
so the pain becomes an important moment
where a person tries to generate a new
kind of experience in the body to feel
the body in a different way so even
though it's painful it it becomes
pleasurable in a certain sense
you